I just think it's not a particularly
good strategy to go and hunt for every
damn particle that theorists come up
with because there are infinitely many
of those so I'm not surprised that all
these experiments come back finding
nothing I'm not blaming the
experimentalists they're doing exactly
what they should be doing blaming the
theorist for making up all those
particles in the first place it's the
cycle it goes around because the
theorists can justify their work because
there are those experiments they can
look for this with this experiment at
this lab and then on the other hand the
experimentalist justify they experiment
with the theory because there's this guy
who thought up this kind of particle
which has exactly this kind of
interaction that we can measure in our
experiment isn't that great and so then
they make the experiment they don't find
the particle because there wasn't any
reason for it to exist in the first
place I don't have a big problem with
experimentalists who just like to
measure things and try to figure out if
there's something there in a new
parameter range just look at the result
it's not going anywhere